oh spicy hot hot i win
everybody go home justin timberlake and
jessica beale are clearly keeping the
fire alive in their marriage
on thursday the singer and actress were
caught soaking in the sun while cruising
along the mediterranean near one of
italy's most picturesque islands
sardinia
check out jessica rocking a leopard
print bikini and red sunglasses while
lying flat on her stomach as justin who
went for green swim trunks gets cheeky
with his wife
and that's not all the couple clearly
doesn't shy away from showing pda as
they kiss each other passionately while
beachside as it turns out we just still
think the world of each other
it's been a summer of fun for the duo
who will celebrate 10 years of marriage
this fall
and are also parents to sons silas and
phineas
the couple's trip to italy comes just
days after they turned heads at paris
fashion week appearing at kenzo dior and
louis vuitton fashion shows
they even made time for date night in
the city of lights
attending the sadiq pop-up party by made
nightlife and according to an eyewitness
the two were very lovey-dovey
[Music]
latest track stay with me seems to be
the perfect anthem for the summer love
these two are feeling and back in may
jessica revealed to et their trick to
keeping their romance alive it's a
really good question right um
well i'll have to give justin the credit
in this moment
for this one thing that he always says
to me is we might be married but we have
to keep dating
and it's so true you know
you just have to keep making time for
each other and you have to keep making
each other a priority
and do the things that you love together
um
it's not always easy as we all know but
that
those touch point moments i think
kind of
make all the hard times
you know palatable
[Music]
you